bonjour françois al-bacha merci de
répondre à nos questions sur arte france
quelle est la situation à l'heure où on
se parle à beyrouth on a vu des images
d'aix routier bloqué cette journée de
grève nationale journée de colère comme
elle est baptisée est ce qu'elle est
bien suivie partout dans le pays
bonjour refaite la journée est plutôt
calme par rapport aux autres
manifestations qu'on a eus qu'on a pu
avoir par le passé les axes
effectivement compter à l'heure actuelle
certains axes sont sont réouverts la
circulation mais autrement c'est pas
comme ce qu'on a pu voir en 2019 ou demi
après un peu après c'est à dire un
blocage avec des sit-in permanents des
des clash avec les forces de sécurité et
ainsi de suite
hier on a vu un rassemblement qui a
dégénéré devant la banque centrale du
liban est ce qu'il ya des craintes à
nouveau de débordements aujourd'hui ou
peut-être plus tard dans la soirée
lorsque la nuit va tomber
au fait ce qui s'est passé devant la
banque du liban est différent de ce qui
se passe aujourd'hui
hier on a eu une manifestation
devant la banque du liban
qui était en fait dire du fait de
nos déposants et de et de personnes anti
système or aujourd'hui ce qu'on a ce
sont des syndicats qui sont qui ont qui
sont dirigées par des personnes proches
des partis politiques dont du système
ne peut pas vraiment comparer les deux
choses et comment le gouvernement
comment est-ce qu'il peut comment est-ce
qu'il va réagir à cette nouvelle
mobilisation on a l'impression que les
manifestations passent et rien ne se
passe
effectivement c'est
le gouvernement et les partis politiques
ont toujours su en fin de compte
gagner du temps cette manifestation
aujourd'hui du fait de syndicat proche
de parti politique c'est comme une
soupape de sécurité qu'on fait un peu on
laisse un peu filer la pression
justement pour ne pas arriver un
débordement sécuritaire en fin de compte
et à côté de ces syndicats maintenant
qu'ils sont contrôlés par des partis
politiques on a des syndicats
alternatifs qui commence à se mettre en
place et il faut pas oublier que
justement comme parler comme disait l'un
des manifestants il ya des il ya aussi
l'optique d'élections législatives en
mai prochain
mais justement est ce que les élections
c'est une solution vous pose souvent
cette question à vous comme à d'autres
intervenants libanais comment sortir le
liban de la crise on a l'impression que
c'est une impasse et que même les appels
de la communauté internationale n'y font
rien
il n'y a pas au fait de perspectives à
l'heure actuelle de sortie de crise on a
une
au niveau de la communauté
internationale certaines certaines
personnes évoquent le pourrissement
d'une situation que qu'il fallait que
les partis aujourd'hui
cherche le pourrissement de la situation
pour obtenir le déblocage de l'aide
économique sans
répondre aux conditions à ce déblocage
qui sont des conditions de transparence
au niveau jugé économique judiciaire
financiers et ainsi de suite or
aujourd'hui on voit que l'audit
juricomptable de la banque du liban est
bloquée au niveau judiciaire on a ce
bras de fer concernant
l'explosion du port de beyrouth en parti
politique et
donc les victimes
au niveau économique
on a toujours un système économique qui
rejette la responsabilité
au niveau des pères qui système bancaire
et ainsi de suite donc ce sont mon
direct qui jouent vraiment le jeu n'y
croyait de jute fait le pourrir la
situation en totale pour justement
pousser la communauté internationale à
débloquer l'aide mais la communauté
internationale ne craque pas justement
on a vu les conférence de donateurs ces
derniers temps pour le liban organisé
par paris par washington par l'onu avec
une menace de stopper les aides si rien
n'est fait
et on en est où coup d'épée dans l'eau
ou réel effet de levier
pour le moment c'est un coup d'épée dans
l'eau et on a un gouvernement certes
c'est une petite avancée mais depuis
novembre le gouvernement ne se réunit
plus on n'a aucune capacité aujourd'hui
à
riffles adopter des réformes on a un
système judiciaire dont on a des bras de
fer entre banques et jugent entre partis
politiques et juges
ont grevé avoir
un premier un mémorandum datant
d'entente entre le fmi et le
gouvernement libanais fin décembre
pour le moment on évoque une possibilité
d'entendre fin février mais fin février
après les élections législatives
donc une période électorale et donc tout
sera reportée aux calendes grecques
sachant qu'au niveau économique
on est vraiment né en ont face d'un
effondrement
la parité de la libanaise est passé à 33
me livre libanaise coin dollars c'est à
dire c'est une perte de valeur de 94 %
de sa valeur alors que les salaires sont
restées identiques imaginez donc que le
salaire minimum est passé en deux ans de
450 millions de dollars à 20 dollars
sur ce le prix tous les prix vont
augmenter
on l'a dit un manifestation on va dire
sauvage
hier soir manifestation plus organisé
aujourd'hui à quoi est-ce qu'il faut
s'attendre dans les prochains jours dans
la rue au liban
il ya beaucoup d'incertitudes déjà les
prochains jours il ya une tempête les
gens ici ils vont pas sortir quand quand
on en va de la nage à 1200 mètres
d'altitude
donc ça doit un peu calmé les choses
mais au niveau économique les gens n'en
peuvent plus il ya beaucoup de gens qui
sont fatigués qu'ils pensent plutôt à
partir que qu'à continuer à
a
continué a justement à
supporter la situation actuelle et ceux
qui sont condamnés à rester on ne sait
pas comment en fait ils s'en sortent
aujourd'hui
merci beaucoup françois lebel chat
d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous économiste et
fondateur du site d'information
libnanews merci